the US Senate passes a two trillion
dollar coronavirus relief package after
days of fiery debate we will examine the
good the bad and the ugly there's a lot
of all three then more good news on the
scientific front of the pandemic more
fury from the mainstream media
and a major me to allegation against
drumroll please
sleepy Joe Biden we will analyze the
evidence and the accuser then finally
the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles and this
is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
ooh boy if I look tired I am the reason
I am is because I was up all night last
night with senator Ted Cruz who came
straight from the Capitol to our studio
in Washington DC he showed up there
after midnight East Coast time that was
the moment we even started to work on
the podcast because we did an episode of
verdict with Ted Cruz for all of the
minutia and details and goings-on of how
this thing was negotiated you can head
over and check out that podcast we're
going to get to what is in the bill and
what it means for the scientific front
for the political front for the economic
front because I I think look the thing
is a huge bill two trillion dollars
largest stimulus or relief package
whichever you prefer
that we've ever had in American history
some people are saying it's the worst
abomination that has ever passed in the
United States some people are saying
it's all dandy as with any bill like
this there is a lot that's good there is
a lot that's bad and there is a lot that
is downright ugly so we'll get into all
of that but first I've got to thank our
friends over at Rock Auto you know how
much I love Rock Auto Rock Auto is a
family-run business they have been
selling auto parts online for over 20
years which is the entire history of
online there hasn't there hasn't been a
lot more online than that and they've
been just wonderful you know the thing I
like about them is I don't know that
much about cars when I show up to a
brick-and-mortar they first of all they
never have the car parts that I need
that the people at brick-and-mortar then
log on they probably go to Rock Auto
they get the parts and then they up
charge me a lot Rocco does catalog is so
simple to navigate even I can do it you
can find whatever parts you're looking
for in a few easy clicks the other thing
I like is their they don't have any
gimmicks okay they just always have
reliably low prices I really trust these
guys I mean here's an example the Delphi
FG 1456 fuel pump assembly for a 2005 to
2010 Honda Odyssey is three 59.99 and
advanced a big chain store it's only
21679 at rockauto.com
just one example go to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car or truck right Knowles in
there
how did you hear about us box so that
they will know that I sent you what is
in this bill well I get think the first
question you gotta ask is why did it
take so damn long to pass okay we were
supposed to get a vote on this
coronavirus relief package Saturday or
Sunday over the weekend here we are it's
now Thursday and we just got it in the
middle of the night last night so what
happened
first of all Nancy Pelosi happened Nancy
Pelosi came in at the last minute and
basically said we'll only pass the
coronavirus relief package if you also
pass the green new deal in that the
coronavirus relief package it was just
total bogus partisan trash she tried to
use it as an excuse to make airlines
lower their emission standards to make
corporate boards answer to the
government for some intersectional
identity boxes I mean an absolute
fantasy you know it was a really cynical
cheap way to play the whole negotiation
Republicans to their credit did not play
it that way they actually focused
everything on the coronavirus Democrats
did not do that so that took a while to
iron out luckily Nancy Pelosi got
absolutely hammered in the press for
trying to do this so she dropped most of
what she was after then the bill was
slated for a vote
two days ago but it hit a lat
last-minute snag because Senator Lindsey
Graham among others actually including
senator Cruz pointed out that there was
an error in the bill I mean it was just
a bad incentive I don't know if it was
put there intentionally I don't think it
was I think it was simply stupidity it
turned out that the bill actually
incentivized people not to go back to
work here's Lindsey Graham explaining it
if you're a nurse aide making fifteen or
sixteen dollars an hour you're on the
frontlines here a lot of doctors offices
are gonna have to roll back because
elective surgery is no longer a source
of income for a bunch of doctors so you
gonna have all these well trained nurses
they're gonna make $24 an hour on
unemployment
you're literally incentivizing taking
people out of the workforce at a time
when we need critical infrastructure
supplied with workers so that's a big
problem
the bill the the legislation gives an
extra $600 per week in unemployment for
up to four months so that's very very
generous I mean compared to say Italy if
you just look at Texas for example Texas
you can make up to up to around $550 per
month in unemployment if you had $600 to
that that's more than a hundred percent
raise
but then the trouble is your if you
let's say you have paid fifteen bucks an
hour for your job all of a sudden you're
making twenty five maybe twenty eight
dollars an hour for your job you have no
reason to go back to work to make the
fifteen bucks an hour right it'd be much
better for you to stay on unemployment
for the four months that you can get it
you make significantly more money but
that will drag the economy the whole
point of this relief package is to keep
the economy going to prevent a collapse
so if you have an incentive in there
that tells people don't go back to work
you can actually make more money sitting
on your couch that's not going to be
particularly helpful that's actually
gonna be very counterproductive
so the Republicans pointed this out
Democrats didn't care is you got to
remember we'll see later in the show
more evidence of this the Democrats
don't want the economy to recover right
an economy that recovers hurts them in
November so they're trying to drag this
thing out as long as possible all the
new scientific studies that have come
out and scientific analyses that show
that coronavirus may in fact be much
much less dire and much less deadly than
we previously thought we went through
those studies yesterday from Stanford
analysis from Yale analysis from Oxford
right we went through all of that
they're hiding that the left doesn't
want to report on it because they want
the economic crisis to go on so the bad
news is the Republicans lost when it
came to that unemployment provision it's
that's too bad that's a just a dumb
provision of the bill it is going to
hamper the economy we're spending two
trillion dollars on this thing and
frankly we might end up spending more
but you know if if you're spending two
trillion dollars you you want the thing
to help the unemployment situation you
want it to help the economy that is
gonna hurt it that's too bad that's one
of the bad portions of the bill a bill
gives a hundred billion dollars to
hospitals that's probably a good idea
you know you still want to prepare as
though this is a very very very serious
at
demmick you want to prepare for the
worst-case scenario you just don't want
to destroy the economy while you do it
so 100 billion dollars to hospitals make
sense to me 58 billion dollars to
Airlines none of us wants to give credit
to Airlines but we do need air travel
the airlines are absolutely hemorrhaging
money right now this was agreed to by
both parties it just seems like the sort
of thing you have to do it's unfortunate
but probably have to do it I include a
tax credit for retaining your workforce
so businesses if they don't fire their
workforce during the shutdown they will
get a major tax credit I think it's up
to about $5,000 per employee great idea
what we want to incentivize here is not
not simply businesses remaining
profitable or if they're not going to
remain profitable at least keeping cash
what we want to incentivize is them not
firing their workforce this is a great
way to do it
very smart portion of the bill under 50
billion dollars to state and local
government this is probably going to be
wasteful this is something the Democrats
were asking for and Republicans more or
less caved
now there's a federalism argument here
which is that most of the epidemic
relief is going to come from the states
and the local governments it's not going
to come from the federal level so you
can empower the states to use that money
yeah okay what are they going to really
use the money for probably they're gonna
fritter it away that's too bad if I were
writing the bill that would have been
significantly lower ten and a half
billion dollars to the Pentagon the
Pentagon always gets money in these
bills that's just the way it works and
that's fine I mean this epidemic is is
in many ways a national security issue
so whatever drop in the bucket when
you're talking about two trillion twenty
four billion dollars for farmers and
ranchers that's fine I mean obviously
they're getting disrupted because of
this total shutdown twenty four billion
dollars to food stamps and child
nutrition food stamps is a very abuse
program however in the shutdown one big
issue has been that schools very often
are providing the only nutrition that
children are getting per day and that's
unfortunate and parents should be held
to account for that and if you can't
feed your kid one meal a day or two
meals a day you should not be able to
have a child you know you
should have to answer for that that's
criminal because I think a lot of the
time it's you know we're not talking
about Jean Valjean and lame is you know
people living on the street trying to
steal a loaf of bread very often it's
about poor economic choices and not
prioritizing feeding one's children over
other spending habits and relying on the
government to do that for you
nevertheless you probably had to include
it in there then the most important
provision is 500 billion dollars to
industries these 500 billion dollars
fortunately comes in the form of loans
so it's not simply a five hundred
billion dollar handout now if the
industries and the businesses meet
certain criteria then they will have
those loans forgiven criteria like for
instance not firing your workforce there
also a lot of shackles put on the
businesses so they can't just buy back a
lot of stock they can't they can't just
use this five hundred billion dollar
loan to line their own pockets I'm
pretty fine with that I think actually
that's the best part of the bill that's
the part Republicans we're really
pushing for and the Democrats were
pushing against and then there's maybe
the most controversial part of the bill
which I'll get to in one second first
I've got to thank our friends though at
Express VPM expressvpn is the VPN I
trust that's it I have it on my computer
I got it on my phone I don't want to go
online without it why because if you're
listening to this program something
tells me you listen to some pretty shady
things on the internet maybe you go to
some websites that you know or are not
totally acceptable in society you click
that incognito window you know what I'm
talking about you type in daily wire com
you're not allowed to do that these days
so politically incorrect make sure you
have expressvpn it works on everything
it it protects your information it
protects your online browsing identity
just do it man it's completely worth it
if you're like me you believe your
online activity is your business secure
yourself by visiting expressvpn comm
slash Michael today expr ESS VPN comm
slash Michael you get an extra three
months free expressvpn dot-com what is
it / michael mi CH AE i'll go over there
right now it's like the cost of an
expensive cup of coffee you know like
one one per month you're talking about
what do you pay like
seven bucks a month absolutely worth it
go do it okay the most controversial
part of this as far as I'm concerned is
the $1,200 check that's going out to
some Americans not all Americans but
some Americans if you make more than a
hundred thousand dollars a year you're
not going to get a check and if you make
more than 75 thousand dollars a year the
check starts to get phased out this part
I'm least jazzed about the reason I'm
least jazzed about it is not because
people don't need money people do need
money but it'd be much better for those
people to be able to keep their job than
to just get a one-time $1,200 check from
the government right and so you could
have put those resources into making
sure that we protect those jobs $1,200
check by the way it very likely not
going to do much to stimulate the
economy
there's more or less an economic
consensus about that and the downside of
it is it gets people habituated to this
idea of universal basic income which is
a horrible anti human very bad no good
dumb andrew yang idea so don't care for
that all that much however it was
certainly gonna go in there you know
that was I was being pushed by
Republicans and Democrats and in the
grand scope of this bill you know not
not the biggest issue this is
fundamentally different from tarp or the
Obama era stimulus because those
stimulus packages were reacting to
companies they were bailing out
companies who in many ways had dug their
own grave in this case people didn't dig
their own grave they didn't cause this
problem they had you know we're just
told because of a Chinese epidemic that
they couldn't do business anymore
if this brings us a step closer to
getting out of this China inflicted
economic disaster do I love the bill no
do I think it was necessary yes
is it the least bad option yeah very
possibly very possibly it is and the
thing we're all dealing with even as we
complain about it is the fact that the
coronavirus has a cost so it gets us
it's getting us I think a step closer to
getting out of the economic disaster
it's also getting us closer to getting
out of the China inflicted medical
disaster the you know the stimulus
itself might not be getting a set of
that medical disaster but we are we are
apparently
closer to seeing the light at the end of
the tunnel we noticed this from you know
major scientific experts we went through
some studies yesterday and now dr.
deborah birx who is one of the top
people and the white house coronavirus
task force is saying that the numbers
that we're all hearing the mainstream
media are frightening they're probably
overhyped and the science is actually
much more hopeful numbers that have been
put out there are actually very
frightening to people but I can tell you
if you go back and look at Wuhan and who
Bay and all of these provinces when they
talk about 60,000 people being infected
even if you said oh right well there's
asymptomatic sand all of that so you get
to 600,000 people out of 80 million that
is nowhere close to the numbers that you
see people putting out there I think it
is frightened the American people I
think on a freely on a model that you
just run full out you can get to those
numbers if you have zero controls and
you do nothing and we know that every
American is doing something right
this is so important even if you don't
trust China's numbers deborah birx there
is saying okay let's say it's an order
of magnitude more in terms of infections
that's still not a huge percentage in
that area you know a lot of the hysteria
came from that Imperial College study
out of the United Kingdom people
concluded in the United States that two
million Americans could die I mean I
suppose it's possible but increasingly
the analysis shows that might have been
very hyped and what deborah birx is
saying there is maybe you can get to
those numbers on your computer models if
nobody changes any of their behavior if
nobody even starts washing their hands a
little bit more but everybody has
radically changed their behavior so
there would seem to be some place
between don't even wash your hands and
destroy the global economy and lock
everything down and don't leave your
apartment that would be a happy medium
that would mitigate the risk is
significantly and and also acknowledge
the reality of how we all get on in the
world so that's that's what the science
shows however
there is this reaction on the left that
hasn't kept up with the science so with
the left keep saying is we need we need
to listen to the scientists we need to
listen to the analysis and yet when you
get new analysis out of Yale Stanford
Oxford
there were Berks updating people calling
that the mainstream media for hyping
this thing when you get all of that new
information the left doesn't change
their tune here is Andrew Cuomo furious
at the president for declaring that he
hopes to be done with all of this and
get the economy going again by Easter
because of the science
Easter Sunday and you'll have packed
churches all over a country I think
would be a beautiful time based on what
no expert backed him up on the Easter
call not one piece of science not one
projection sorry I'm very sorry I have
to make an apology here - Andy Cuomo I'm
sorry for confusing you with your
brother Chris Cuomo the fredo of the
Cuomo family I'm sorry that I confused
the far superior Cuomo damning with
faint praise but still with the Fredo of
the family and what Fredo just said is
simply not true right I just recited to
you the scientists we've read in the
last few days who have stated explicitly
that fears of coronavirus the panic of
coronavirus is overblown including a
Nobel laureate including people from all
those fancy schools with all those fancy
degrees and all those fancy
professorships you know those two
Stanford scientists we read yesterday
said that the mortality rate might be
orders of magnitude lower than what is
being projected and reported in the
press Oxford study says the same thing
but apparently Crisco dr. Chris Cuomo
professor Chris Cuomo knows so much more
about the science capital s with a
trademark over the e than the actual
scientists do this is typical of the
left they always they invoke science as
though it were a deity as they're there
they're giving homage they're worshiping
the science but that doesn't have a lot
to do with the academic analysis it has
a whole lot to do with the kind of
invention of science as merely a firm
their own prejudiced and preconceived
notions Chris Cuomo goes on I'm not sure
the president knows
Easter's theme its rebirth and renewal
but assuming he does why would he invite
the opposite of rebirth and renewal fact
more than 100 Americans died from corona
virus today more than 700 total the
virus is accelerating so with those as
the facts give me one reason it would be
safe or smart or effective to reopen
during the period of most cases fact he
says a hundred people died of corona
virus in one day another fact a hundred
people died in car accidents on the very
same day and every single day when you
just state these facts completely out of
context they they don't tell us much
about the thing we're discussing Chris
Cuomo says that the virus is
accelerating is that true or is
diagnosis just accelerating the big
complaint from the left is the testing
has not been available now testing is
more widely available of course
diagnosis is going to increase but are
we sure that the diagnosis increasing is
because of the virus itself accelerating
I think actually the models we've looked
at around the world suggests probably
that isn't true
when you see spikes in flu related
pneumonia related illnesses and deaths
even a couple of months ago do we think
that has no relationship to the virus we
really think the virus just dropped out
of thin air on March 1st or something at
the end of February probably not I don't
think so Chris Cuomo says that it is a
fact that Easter day will be especially
bad for coronavirus that's not a
scientific fact that is the prediction
of a TV political pundit and the fredo
of the Cuomo family not a fact the most
troubling aspect of this for me is the
left's using science capital S T M over
the e as an excuse to avoid political
debate you see this exemplified by a
writer named Molly Jong fast who I love
using her tweets and things as examples
because she's just so out there I don't
mean that as an insult I mean she's out
there giving
the opinion of the left she's kind of
honest or guileless about it so she
tweets out oMG I would kill for a
presser with only doctors and scientists
hashtag doctors only press conferences
she doesn't want Trump or the
coronavirus task force to give press
conferences just the scientists and the
doctors first of all something tells me
she wouldn't actually like a presser
with those scientists I don't think
she'd like a professor with the Yale
scientist dr. Katz who wrote in the New
York Times this has been overhyped and I
think she'd want a presser with the
Stanford scientists I don't think she'd
want a press here with the Oxford
scientists right she only wants a
professor with the scientists who she
and others on the Left have been citing
but beyond that I don't want my policy
dictated by scientific tyrants okay I
don't I didn't I didn't elect dr. fowey
okay I like dr. fatty but I didn't elect
the guy I don't want him to have total
control over our response to the
coronavirus epidemic
I didn't elect these scientific experts
we have politics in this country so that
we can discuss and debate different
priorities politics is not a clean-cut
science it's not like there's always a
clear answer it's about weighing
different priorities taking into account
in our country the opinions of the
American people viewing things not just
through a lens of completely stopping a
virus which is not possible but also by
balancing our liberties also by
balancing or what is likely to occur
also by balancing the economy so I
certainly don't want that the left you
know scratch out leftist and you get a
tyrant on underneath and I think that's
what we're seeing here but ironically in
this case the tyrants that they want to
put up are increasingly disagreeing with
them we've got a lot more to get to
we've got to go to Trump calling out the
fake news in a beautiful way we've got
to get to how the corona virus is a
gendered crisis but not in the way that
the left thinks it is and then we got to
get to Joe Biden's me too moment first
however I've got to thank our friends
over at beard supply oh yeah man if you
are sitting at home and you were giving
Quarantine beard a shot you probably
know it's not as easy as it looks for me
I'm really hoping beard supply could
help me grow a beard you know because
I'm really good I can grow a beard
except for like right here and so I got
this like one little patch and I look
like I'm a 15 year old boy beards can
dry out they can get itchy they can look
dumb okay beard supply helps keep your
beard healthy itch free soft and
smelling great more than ten thousand
beards agree beard supply products are
the best out there can ten thousand
beards be wrong I don't think so here's
what Jacob's beard says Jacob's beard
says Chuck Norris added me to his list
of worthy opponents after I used beard
supply wow that is one excited and
aggressive sounding beard isn't it head
on over to beard supply its offering
Michael no show listeners 25% off right
now beard supply.com use promo code
knowles canada wles
that is a beard supply.com use promo
code notes que no WL e s it is now
transparent that the left wants this
crisis to go on regardless of what
economists suggest and regardless of
what the medical experts suggest so the
the washington post just sends out this
new piece it's titled
trump is spreading false hope for a
virus cure and that's not the only
damage this is an editorial put out by
the editorial board not by scientists by
the editorial board which says that the
drug that's now being touted not just by
Trump and also by Andy Cuomo by a lot of
people hydroxychloroquine has shown
promise on in terms of mitigating the
virus and yet they're saying it's false
hope there's no cure stop it don't go
away and they'd actually talk about how
it's it's been shown to be somewhat
effective but and more effective than
anything else we've looked at but they
don't want that answer kind of reminds
me how in the New York Times they ran
this op-ed the other day from dr. Katz
from Yale saying this is all being
overhyped and then the editorial board
comes out and says no no it's not panic
be worried be alarmed so you got the
scientists saying not a huge deal then
you got the journalists who who I use
that term loosely they're just left-wing
political operatives out to get
Donald Trump and every other Republican
they're the one saying no you should
panic no you should worry president
Trump has had enough of this he he was
giving another one of his daily pressors
one of the greatest things to come out
of this coronavirus pandemic and he
called them out as fake news is this
Easter timeline based on your political
interest you said that the media wants
the country remain close to know the
media would like to see me do poorly in
the election I think I think what is
that just so you understand are you
ready I think there are certain people
that would like it not to open so
quickly I think there are certain people
that would like it to do financially
poorly because they think that would be
very good as far as defeating me at the
polls and I don't know if that's so but
I do think it's so that a lot of that
there are people in your profession that
would like that to happen I think it's
very clear I think it's very clear that
there are people in your profession that
write fake news you do she does there
are people in your profession that write
fake news they would love to see me for
whatever reason because we've done one
hell of a job nobody's done the job that
we've done and it's lucky that you have
this group here right now for this
problem or you wouldn't even have a
country left bingo baby there it is some
people in that profession are writing
fake news not everybody but some people
certainly are a great example of this
The Washington Post I kid you not ran an
article going after a random guy on
Twitter for suggesting that maybe we
shouldn't panic and maybe we shouldn't
destroy the economy I kid you not here's
the tweet Scot McMillan a 56 year old
lawyer tweeted that it's more vital to
revive the economy than to save people
who are not productive like the elderly
and infirm so I called his parents great
crack reporting guys Wow
democracy dies in darkness The
Washington Post is so pissed off that
this pandemic is not going to completely
destroy the world
we're not going to shut down the global
economy for six months that they are now
finding random people on Twitter this
guy stopped Scot McMillan had 400
Twitter followers now four hundred
thousand four hundred and then found his
parents phone number and called them to
tattletale on their son and guess what
the parents said they agreed that's the
best part of it all
the Barretts have told the washington
post yeah maybe we shouldn't destroy the
global economy based on these numbers
that you know some people are going to
become ill with the virus because people
you know with viruses all the time you
don't freak out about the other viruses
but this one is politically convenient
so anyway a great example of very
embarrassing for the Washington Post
even even that they would run it I mean
you'd think that they would come to
their senses and some self-awareness but
self-awareness is just simply not a
trait among the left so this is also a
gendered crisis is it not this is what
we are being told by the political left
specifically by an Australian senator
marine Farooqi this Australian senator
is very upset now she's right in that
there is a gender component to the
coronavirus but it's not exactly the one
that she says it is it's not forget that
Corbett 19 is a gendered crisis nurses
nurse AIDS teachers child carers and
early childhood educators h care workers
and cleaners are mostly women they are
on the front line of this public health
crisis and carry a disproportionate risk
of being exposed to the virus let's also
not forget that not all homes are safe
places quarantine or self isolation at
home will put women and children at risk
women's advocates and domestic violence
experts are warning us the domestic
abuse increases during times of crisis
and I'm terribly worried that these
warnings have not been heeded by this
government that has long resisted
adequate funding for the needed
resources and refuges okay so what she's
saying is just not true the vast
majority of coronavirus patients are men
so it's a gendered crisis in that it is
affecting men more but the left can't
that because men there are not victims
men can never be victims only women can
be victims the Atlantic ran a piece the
coronavirus is a disaster for feminism
pandemics affects men and women
differently purely as a physical illness
the coronavirus appears to affect women
less severely so at least they admit
that purely as a viral medical physical
illness but as a spiritual illness right
they go on in the past few days the
conversation about the pandemic is
broadened
yeah it's broadened cuz all your facts
are falling apart so now you've gotta
broaden it into politics
the coronavirus smashes up the bargain
that so many dual earner couples have
made in the developed world we can both
work because someone else is looking
after our children instead couples will
decide which one of them takes the hit
what a disgusting thing to write you're
saying like yeah the promise of the
developed world is that none of us has
to raise our children anymore we can
just pay people to do that for us but
now one of us is gonna have to take the
hit of actually interacting with our
child oh woe is me how awful
shows you how perverse these guys are
looking at it by the way we're just
getting some breaking news it's coming
out of the UK we've been talking about
how the the scientific hysteria is now
breaking down so much if it was based on
the Imperial College study there is now
another expert coming out saying that
unlike what the Imperial College study
said that you know Britain is going to
get decimated by this thing it now seems
that Britain does have enough intensive
care units for the patients that the
Imperial College study which sparked all
this alarmism was just wrong does that
mean we shouldn't take the virus
seriously no of course not we should
take it seriously we should do
everything we can take precautionary
measures wash our hands wash your face
social distance don't kiss people in the
middle of the street but does it mean
that the evidence shows we should shut
down the global economy
I don't think so Buster before we get to
mailbag I've got to get to one quick
story oh boy is this one exciting this
is Joe Biden speaking of women speaking
of a gendered crisis Joe Biden has a
serious me too allegation against him
Tara Reid has apparently been trying to
tell her story since this altercation in
1993 of Joe Biden me too in her now for
some reason we haven't heard about it
until right now here is Tara Reid
explaining him he just said hey come
here Tara and then I handed
the thing and he greeted me he
remembered my name and then it we were
alone and it was the strangest thing
there was no like exchange really he
just had me up against the wall and I
was wearing like a skirt and you know
business skirt but I wasn't wearing
stockings it was kind of a hot day that
day and I was wearing heels and I
remember my legs had been hurting from
the marble you know of the Capitol like
walking and I remember that kind of
stuff I remember like I was wearing a
blouse and he just hugged me up against
the wall and the wall was cold and I
remember he it happened all at once the
gym bag I don't know where when I handed
it to him was gone and then his hands
were on me and underneath my clothes and
yeah and then he went um he went down my
skirt but then up inside it and he kind
of traded me with those seniors oh man
that's a whole lot more than shoulder
massages that's much more than we've
heard from Biden before you know this
woman she she came out a little while
ago and said that Biden put his hands on
her shoulders and ran his fingers up and
down her neck she did that it last
spring after Lucy Flores another
political opponent of Joe Biden this
came out and said basically the same
thing I definitely believe that sort of
thing happened but only now we're
hearing he what he actually just went
went down and got like very aggressive
with her she concludes her story for him
saying first like as he was doing it do
you want to go somewhere else and then
him saying to me when I pulled away he
got finished doing what he was doing and
I I was pulled back and he said he said
come on man
I heard she liked me and it's that
phrase stayed with me because I kept
thinking what I might have said and I
can't remember exactly if he said I
thought or if I heard but it's like he
implied like that I had done this like I
don't know
well look the phrase come on man is a
classic Biden ism we hear him say that
all the time come on man hey come on man
so serious allegation do I believe her
no not saying it couldn't have happened
but I need more evidence before I'm
willing to say that this actually
happened why do I feel skeptical about
her account
it's been a really long time and we've
never heard anything about this we've
never heard similar accounts we've heard
that Joe Biden gets creepy with the
shoulder massages and the hair smelling
but we've never heard this kind of thing
right he's he's not considered a
womanizer in DC doesn't have the
reputation of Bill Clinton the the
expose seems too contrived she came out
a year ago and said that he gave her
shoulder massages and then that didn't
work to take him down so now she's
trying a new story okay it just seems a
little contrived maybe it happened but
evidence doesn't seem to back that up
and then the other problem is she does
seem like a genuine nut so there's a
medium article that she wrote his since
deleted it but it's been circulating
where she says she she left college
because her she left politics rather
because America was too anti-russia and
she loves Russia and she says I love
Russia with all my heart I can't
understand the xenophobia that's come
from my own American government quote
President Putin scares the power elite
in America because he's a compassionate
caring visionary leader look whatever
you think about Vladimir Putin
compassionate is probably not one of the
words that I would use right that the
ex-kgb thug who murders journalists not
compassionate maybe you can say he's a
typical Russian leader or he's a strong
Russian leader but I don't know that
compassion that's pretty weird President
Putin has higher approval ratings in
America than the American president I
don't know if that's true
President Putin is beloved by Russia and
he's not going anywhere okay so to
President Putin I say keep your eyes to
the beautiful future and maybe just
maybe America will come to see Russia as
I do okay this is just one example one
thing that we know about the girl is she
pushes Russian propaganda and loves
flagger Putin so just makes me think
she's not totally all there with it who
knows we don't we don't really know
anything anything else about the gal but
from all the evidence we see here I
won't take this
terribly seriously except for this
reason what's good for the goose is good
for the gander Joe Biden during the
Brett Kavanaugh thing by the way the
allegations against Brett Kavanaugh were
much less serious and much less credible
than the allegations against Joe Biden
all right at least we know Joe Biden
gets creepy with people and massages
their shoulders and smells them and
stuff Rick Cavanaugh no evidence he ever
did any of that during Cavanaugh Biden
says what should happen is the woman
should be given the benefit of the doubt
and not be you know abused again by the
system I hope that they understand what
courage it takes for someone to come
forward and relive what they believe
happened to them and let them state it
but treat her with respect okay buddy
well it looks like we're gonna do that
to you too because if we're gonna
completely destroy due process rights
and we're going to allow political
adversaries to come and destroy people
with uncredible allegations then what's
good for the goose is good for the
gander we will get to the mailbag we're
typically running late first I gotta say
goodbye to Facebook in YouTube you know
we launched the all-access show all
access live we're coming to you every
day during this quarantine be sure to go
sign up a daily wire.com slash subscribe
you get so much content that shows only
four all-access members right now we're
opening up to all of our members so head
on over there if you're enjoying it
upgrade your membership daily wire.com
slash subscribe we'll be right back
I am going to burn through these
questions because we only have limited
time I want to answer as many as
possible first one from Matt dear
austere religious podcaster and Lord of
kff a your comment about Italy not
having a functioning government since
Octavian caused me to reflect on Rome's
first emperor was Octavian a tyrant or a
father to the Romans in the same vein as
Washington or Lincoln keep up the great
work came for Ben stayed for Michael a
great question
Octavian or Caesar Augustus is one of
the most interesting historical figures
that has ever lived by far the greatest
leader of Rome and now you're asking to
compare him to Washington or Lincoln
that's very difficult because Octavian
kind of shows us that Rome is moving
away from a Republican form of
government into an imperial form of
government whereas Washington or Lincoln
were strong advocates of a Republican
form of government so in that way not
similar at all but Octavian was a really
terrific ruler people talk about the end
of the Roman Republic and how everything
went downhill don't forget you had
centuries of peace and prosperity after
Rome became an empire for a while it was
pretty good and then it fell apart and
there's also the interesting historical
coincidence with Agra Caesar Augustus or
Octavian which is that he lives a kind
of parallel life to Christ at the time
of Christ so Christ is called the Prince
of Peace right he's his father is an
adopted father Joseph because his true
father is God he's called the Son of God
he Institute's peace on earth Caesar
Augustus also an adopted child is called
the son of the Divine because they
viewed Caesar Augustus as in a way
divine he also instituted an era of
peace called the Pax Romana and it
happened at the same time you can call
that coincidence I think probably it's a
little closer to Providence from Annie
quick question on the lockdowns episode
you did with Jeremy you mentioned your
go to drink when you're sick is a hot
toddy
you know it do you have a favorite
recipe you can share I did a search and
discover there are many variations of
what would seem to be a simple classic
concoction things
in advance yes my recipe is very simple
very basic hot water lemon honey
Weller's bourbon okay that's it
some people put tea some people use
other kind of whiskey's I like Weller
and I like my lemon just good that's
what you know those two things killed
the disease and hot water and honey
that's it that's all you want from Nick
dear Michael if you were only allowed
one item from the store before lit being
locked in under house-arrest what one
item would you grab thanks eggs duh you
don't really need toilet paper for like
you don't need a lifetime supply of
toilet paper you know if you're stuck at
home maybe you've got a really nice
palatial home and you've got to be de
you know you've got a shower you've got
other pieces of paper you'll be fine
without that do you need water no you
got a sink do you need booze well
hopefully you're stocked up already same
thing with stogies what you do need
those eggs because with egg wish you can
make breakfast obviously you can make
fresh pasta you can make bread
everybody's already got flour and stuff
in their home so you just what you need
is the eggs that's what people should be
buying the stores out of from Vanessa
dear Michael where the hell is the U n
all we hear is how important it is to
have a strong United Nations but when it
comes time to do anything like that it
seems like the USA is the only one to
bear the burden have you done any
investigation into where the UN is now
like what are they doing and should the
establishment continue thanks where is
the UM the simple answer to that
question is it's on the future site of
the Trump luxury condominium on the east
side of New York overlooking the East
River yeah the United Nations is a
almost entirely useless institution
which you've got to remember is as as
John Bolton famously said there is no
such thing as the United Nations there
is the interest of the United States and
there is the international community
sometimes those two things intersect in
which case the United Nations can be a
fine vessel to mediate that but when
those things don't intersect
it doesn't matter I mean the UN just
doesn't do anything very often what it
does is give a platform for the worst
people on earth to come and lecture us
about how awful we are and that's
ridiculous and probably we shouldn't pay
for that anymore in so much as the UN
allows us to build some consensus to do
what we were already going to do anyway
I suppose that's fine but that sure is
an expensive way to do it from Tyler to
the excellent Michael Knowles the man
with the greatest hair and my spirit
animal
I'm getting married hopefully without
delays from Lulu in May and my fiance's
Catholic a nun Methodist after attending
multiple masses pre-cana classes and
listening to your show I felt more of a
connection with the Catholic religion my
question is what is the process to
convert and how long is this process
thank you for all that you do well Tyler
congratulations
I'm very pleased to hear that you're
getting married and that you're
interested in coming back to the church
and swimming across the Tiber as we say
the process is actually very
straightforward you can enlist in
something called RCIA classes this is
the Rite of Christian initiation and
you'll learn everything that you need to
learn you know it's not just like you're
jumping in without any knowledge of what
it is really great classes I've got
friends of mine who have converted from
Judaism taking the RCIA classes who have
converted from evangelical Christianity
or other Protestant groups they've all
gotten a lot even if you already know a
ton about Christianity which if you're
interested like this you probably do
still really great refresher and might
show you things you haven't heard before
so get into RCIA there are several steps
in the process and then you can become a
full-on Catholic by next Easter or maybe
even sooner depending on your your
diocese from Claire Michael how do you
define if an extremist group or regime
is right-wing or left-wing it seems that
most belief systems this extreme don't
even remotely resemble either mainstream
view so I never know how it is decided
whether a group is right wing or left
wing thanks well when you get to the
fringes and the extremes it does get a
little bit complicated I mean the
classic example of this is the Nazis or
the Nazis right wing in a way they are
you know some conservatives want to say
they have nothing to do with the
right-wing now they do have something to
do with the right-wing they are a little
more interested in history they're a
little more interested in tradition
they're a little more interested in
[Music]
I don't know monarchy or a kind of like
perverted version of monarchy which
tends to be historically more of a
right-wing preference so in that way I
guess they're right wing they're also
very left-wing in the sense that Nazism
National Socialism well for one is a
form of socialism but it's also very
modernist I mean it's very it was very
secular it was actually very
anti-christian anti religious all of
that is very left-wing it's in many ways
it was pagan paganism wasn't adopted by
many members high-ranking Nazis so in
that way it's very left-wing it's very
hard to classify it the trouble is that
even our concept of right and left comes
from the French Revolution people who
sat on the right side were Royalists
more favorable toward the established
order and people who were on the left
side were more radical and so that
moment the French Revolution was such a
radical moment in many ways the
beginning of our modern era doesn't
totally correspond to all those modern
movements I'm a conservative but I
despise so much of political modernism
that you know to put it into a modernist
framework would be so antithetical to
anything that I like so you've got to
speak about it precisely to say it's
totally left-wing you're totally right
wing very often misses the point all
right we've got so many more questions
but we just don't have time I'm sorry
I've tried to bring you everything that
I possibly can be as so much is
happening in our politics in our biology
and our medical field and in our economy
so that's the update for now of course
this is changing by the moment so
perhaps on Monday everything will be
completely different again and we will
get into it then in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
whanau ski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka geneva
production assistant ryan love the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there